hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast is free 2508 vitamin G
the next-generation vitamin D marker
presented by Nicholas hero's he is a
principal scientist at the asuras
immunoassays I am Marjorie Torrence of
lab routes and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by Larry Roberts is leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button to locate
located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen
what answer as many of your questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that
you'll be viewing the presentation in
the slide window to enlarge the window
just click on this green icon located on
the lower right if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A button to let us know
that you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the button in the bottom
left corner involved the process to
obtain your credit please join me in
welcoming Nikolas Europe I will now turn
the presentation over to him
good morning or good afternoon everybody
my name is Nikolai Gogol I'm based in
Belgium my background is in organic
chemistry and I work for a dieter sim
analysis for seven years now starting in
the development of vitamin D assays and
now kind of working the area of free
vitamin D which will be the topic of
four to the webinar and the title of the
webinar is is 325 hydroxy vitamin D in
the next generation vitamin D marker
this is the outline of the presentation
I'm gonna start with an introduction on
vitamin D metabolism it will be a very
general introduction but it will allow
us to really set the crown for the depth
the rest of the presentation
then we're gonna move to total 25
hydroxy vitamin D and then introduce the
325 at Roxy vitamin D concept I'm gonna
then discuss the different conditions
which affect the free and total
equilibrium and then present you a few
key studies on 325 hydroxy vitamin D at
the end of the presentation I will
explain you how you can measure or
evaluate the concentration of 325
hydroxy vitamin D and then there will be
some take-home messages and a Q&A
session so let's start with vitamin D
metabolism and as you probably know
vitamin D is sourced from two different
ways of two different sources the main
source of vitamin D comes from the Sun
and the Sun is transforming the 7 d
hydro cholesterol by the action of UVB
into vitamin d3 which is drawn on slides
the other source of vitamin D is food or
supplements and the food can be
fortified with vitamin D or not food is
usually usually very poor in vitamin D
only some food sources like fat fish
contain significant vitamin D from food
or form supplements you can have two
different forms of vitamin D the D 3 and
the D 2 once vitamin D is in the body it
it is transported to the liver where it
is transformed by an enzyme into 25
hydroxy vitamin D 25 hydroxy vitamin D
is then further converted in the kidney
by the one hydroxylase enzyme into 125
dihydroxy vitamin d other tissues or
organs are also able to do this
transformation and so to obtain 125
hydroxy vitamin D 425 a top seed I mean
the 125 the hydroxy vitamin D is then
excreted through 24 hydroxylation so it
goes to 24 25 the hydroxy vitamin D or
and 124 25 o h3 vitamin D 25 hydroxy
vitamin D is currently the best marker
of vitamin D deficiency and is used
worldwide in all laboratories and
hospitals to really evaluate if someone
is vitamin D deficient people sometimes
are going to talk about vitamin D or 25
galaxy vitamin D or total vitamin the
oldest terms usually they refer to 25 at
Roxy vitamin D what we mean by total 25
at Roxy vitamin D is two different
things
some people will mean total is the sum
of the d2 and d3 forms and as you will
see later in this presentation
total can also mean the free fraction
plus the bone fraction so if you use the
term total it can refer to two different
concepts now I'm going to talk a little
bit about total 25ft vitamin D which as
I said before is the currently best the
best marker to evaluate vitamin D
deficiency it is used by laboratories
and hospitals in different situations
and the first one of course is to
diagnose
people for vitamin D deficiency so are
you vitamin D levels too low in that
case you can be classified as vitamin D
insufficient or deficient depending on
the concentration so this is really the
first application of this test the
second application is to monitor people
which are supplemented with vitamin D so
after you're diagnosed people for
vitamin D vitamin D deficiency we will
provide them with supplements and the
vitamin D test is also there to monitor
and the treatment so to see if the
supplements amount is sufficient to
reach optimal levels of vitamin D the
last application of this test is a
little bit less of use but it can be
used to diagnose the item in the
toxicity in case of huge intakes but
that's a very rare situation and it
happens mainly because of manufacturer's
mistake when they manufacture
supplements you can see those two graphs
that the number of vitamin D tests in
laboratories has really increased a lot
the last 10 five years the poor example
is from laboratory in Calgary area and
you really see that the number of tests
has really exploded the last years the
graph below I think is food France also
showing an increase in the number of
vitamin D testings there are different
reasons for that people have been
discovering new applications people
awareness also increased the number of
assays on the market especially
automated assays as also increased all
these things explain the situation why
we have so many vitamin D test now
running in the laboratories there are
some issues associated with the this 25
hydroxy vitamin D tests the first one
and a lot of people are talking about
that is laboratory to laboratory
variability so if you take the same
sample in different laboratories you
might find discrepancies or different
results and for that the VD s P program
has been created by the PDS
P stands for a vitamin D standardization
program and the aim of this program the
ability of this program is really to
standardize vitamin D assays and try to
reduce those discrepancies the next
issue with 25 at oxy vitamin D
concentrations is the inconsistency in
reference values on this table which I'm
sorry for that is in French you can see
the different institutions from
different countries and different areas
of the world I've established different
reference values so in some countries
you might speak about deficiency below
for example 10 nanograms per ml in some
other countries it will be below 20 etc
etc and that's a that's a main concern
and people do not really know which one
they have to use depending on which
institution they rely the third issue
with 25 C vitamin D is the inconsistency
in some clinical studies I see quite a
number of clinical studies which are
published and which show opposite
results to each others so some clinical
studies will show a benefit of vitamin D
versus obtain certain disease some other
clinical studies will show a negative
effect of vitamin D against the same
disease and if you do meta-analysis of
all the studies you end up with a graph
like this
it is presented here with effects which
are positive or negative so at the end
people do not really know what to think
what are the reasons for those issues
well for calibrations issues and for
laboratory to laboratory viability There
is obviously a calibration issue and for
a long time there there was no reference
method or no reference sample for
vitamin D the VD SP program has really
had there to establish reference methods
to hazardous reference materials and to
discuss with manufacturers and
laboratories to try to harmonize the
item in the assays and those calibration
issues no more or less disappears from
from the laboratory so this is no much
better situation for the two other
points so the inconsistency in reference
values but also in the results of
clinical studies there is no easy
explanation one of the explanation might
be that actually total 25 adequacy
vitamin D might not always be the
optimal marker and you can see not that
are some other vitamin D markers that
are used in some cases or not and the
first one is 125 dihydroxy right and the
active form of vitamin D this value is
used in laboratory since probably more
than 20 years but it's very specific for
one application and is usually tested
when you have a problem with your
kidneys so when you have kidney disease
it is not a marker of vitamin B
deficiency
24:25 dihydroxy vitamin D is a recent
hype let's say it has been studied a
little bit those last years and is no
use or can be used in the diagnosis of
idiopathic infantile epochal sinus or
iih the c3 epimer of 25 hydroxy vitamin
D has been also studied a little bit so
far people have not found a clinical
utility for it
but it does an importance in the
accuracy of the measurement of 2530
vitamin D because it can interact with
the results you obtain in your vitamin D
test
non hydroxylated vitamin D form so the
form you really source from the Sun and
from the food has also received a little
bit of research but it's not yet very
clear what is the role of this of these
metabolites and the last one is 325i
dropsy vitamin D which is obviously the
topic of this webinar and which I'm
going to discuss in the in the next
slides let's talk about the concept of
325 C vitamin D and let's start with
this slide so on this slide you see how
2530 vitamin D is distributed in the
body 25 hydroxy vitamin D is a
hydrophobic molecule so it is really not
soluble in water so not soluble in blood
or plasma so it is transported by
binding proteins like a lot of small
molecules and in the case of 25 hydroxy
vitamin D the main transport protein is
d BP vitamin D binding protein which
binds about 88 90 percent of 25 at oxy
vitamin albumin which is a more general
protein can also bind about 10 to 12
percent of 25 Alexa vitamin D although
the concentration of albumin is much
higher than the concentration of D BP
the affinity of albumin 4:25 Roxie
vitamin D is much lower so this is the
reason why it only binds at 10 to 12
percent and then on the bottom of the
slide there is a small fraction which is
the free form so that the form that is
not bound to any protein this small
fraction represents about 0.04 person so
it's a very very small fraction but you
will see it is very important so when we
talk about total 25 out of C vitamin D
which is the the concentration the test
that people are running at the moment it
is the sum of these three fractions the
DBP fraction the albumin fraction and
the free fraction
typically the concentration are between
10 and 15 and a grams burnin 325 hydroxy
vitamin d is this red fraction it a few
a very small percentage of the total
and in terms of concentration we can
talk about two to eight picograms per
milliliter let me introduce you now the
three hormone hypothesis this hypothesis
says that the biological activity of a
given hormone is affected by its unbound
or free rather than protein bone
concentration in the plasma and you have
example existing for years
in papers in literature and in
laboratories as well like the free
tirade or moan so free t3 and free t4
which are now measured a lot and
sometimes even more than the total
concentrations free testosterone and
free cortisol are two other cases so in
those cases people have found that the
concentration of the free hormone is
better linked to its biological activity
than the concentration of the total
hormone and this was proven in research
but also in igd laboratories know for
vitamin D the situation is slightly
different and I'm going to explain why
25 hydroxy vitamin D which is a
parameter that laboratories are
measuring is not the biologically active
form of vitamin D it is 125 hydroxy
vitamin E so on one hand we have a
biologically active form the 125 but on
the other hand we are not measuring this
form so it's a free hormone I put this
is also valid for vitamin D that's the
question on this slide on this picture
you see that I'm 125 dihydroxy vitamin D
is formed into some cells for example in
that case proximal tubule epithelial
cells and 125 the hydroxy vitamin D is
formed in those cells from 25 hydroxy
vitamin there is a conversion inside the
cell
4:25 at Roxy vitamin D to be transported
into the cells there are two options
option a is a diffusion through the
membrane of the free form because the
form that is bound to binding proteins
is too big is too hydrophobic it cannot
cross the cell membrane so in mechanism
a the free form of 25 attack C vitamin D
crosses the membrane and is then
converted into 125 dihydroxy vitamin D
which is the active form in mecca's
mechanics and B sorry bones 25 a drop C
vitamin D and mainly the gdp-bound form
is internalized through a protein
receptor named Nagaland and once it is
internalized it can be free liberated
from the binding protein into 25 hydroxy
vitamin D which is then converted into
the 125 dihydroxy form so there are two
mechanisms possibles possible and this
was of course studied by different
people and people found that in most
extraordinary tissues there is no mega
limbs so the passive diffusion mechanism
is the mechanism in those conditions in
that case what is important is the
concentration of 325 AD oxidize annually
because the concentration of 325 hydroxy
vitamin D outside of the cell is linked
to the concentration of 25 Eric's
vitamin D inside the cell and is there
linked the concentration of the active
form in result issues the situation is
different
there is mcallen uptake and in that case
the two mechanisms are present with the
mega lean mechanisms being the majority
in that case the total 25 C vitamin D
concentration is the most important and
not anymore the concentration of free
ride energy
I'm going to show you know how the free
total vitamin the equilibrium is
affected by different conditions what we
have seen from slide just before is that
the concentration of 320 500 C vitamin D
is at least as important as the
concentration of total 25 alexi revenue
if you take LC mono-ethnic population
the 325 a toxic concentration is always
the same percentage of total 25 Aleksey
vitamin E this percentage is represented
by the letter Y here so it means that
let's say it for example always 0.03
percent of the concentration of total
vitamin E in that case even if free
vitamin D is important you can just use
your total vitamin D as is know in
laboratories and from that point you can
have a good evaluation of vitamin D
deficiency because it will be translated
automatically into the concentrations of
free vitamin D if you are deficient
measuring total vitamin D you will also
be deficient measuring free right and
there will be no difference in the
evaluation of vitamin D deficiency in
other conditions the situation is
totally different and the first
conditions are the ones in which the
concentration of the binding protein DBP
is Alder is modified and those
conditions are listed here at the renal
disease pregnancy liberal disease
intensive care patients women taking
oral contraceptives or hormone
replacement therapy obesity and
proteinuria let's take the example of
pregnancy during pregnancy and that's
seen from the first trimester to the
third one DBP concentration increased by
about 50 percent in that case because
you have more binding protein you will
have more 25 hydroxy vitamin D in the
bone form and you will have less 25
hydroxy vitamin D in the free form
because of that you will also have less
less 25 hydroxy vitamin D inside of the
cell so you will have less of the active
form of vitamin D so if you measure
total 25 hydroxy vitamin D in pregnant
woman we will measure mainly the bone
form and actually this does not
represent anymore the biological action
of vitamin D because in that case the
biological action is driven by the
concentration of 325 AD oxy vitamin D
which is reduced in this case the risk
for this population is that you will
miss classify people when measuring
total vitamin D total 25 hydroxy vitamin
D you may think that pregnant women as
optimal levels of vitamin D because you
are measuring the total actually she
might still be deficient because what is
important in this population is to
measure the concentration of free right
and Mindy so that's the first condition
which is pretty important the other
condition of the other situation in
which the concentration of pre vitamin D
is very important is when you work with
different ethnicities the reason is that
those different ethnicities will have
different forms of vitamin D binding
protein
these are polymers and they are in total
six different polymers and for DBP for
example blacks and Asians F mainly the
GC 1 F form and whites
mainly the GC 1 s form ok why is this
important because those different forms
have different affinities for 25/8 Roxy
right immunity for example in blacks and
Asians where the GC 1 F form is mature
form you have a DBP with lower affinity
for 25 FC vitamin D if you have a
protein with a lower affinity for $25 GC
vitamin D you will have less of the bone
form and you will have more of the free
form if you have more of the free form
you will have more
25 hydroxy vitamin D in the cell and you
will F more of the biological form of
vitamin D so more activity again if you
measure total 25 out of C vitamin D you
might you may find a lower concentration
if you measure 325 hydroxy vitamin D you
may find a higher concentration or a
different vitamin D deficiency status
this difference in affinity is still
under debate but let's say that the
principle is there and if that is true
then 3 vitamin D again is very important
in multi-ethnic cohort or if you are
measuring vitamin D for example in
african-americans or in other ethnic
groups just to summarize this part and
as I explained you the biological
activity of vitamin D is directly linked
to the concentration of 325 Aleksey
vitamin D due to the transport mechanism
of free diffusion and due to the fact
that 25 is then collected into the
active form in a healthy mono-ethnic
population the measurement of total
vitamin D is enough in it it is
representative of the free vitamin D
concentration so in that case you should
not measure free vitamin D it will give
you the same information as total
vitamin D however in conditions with
altered or modified led concentrations
or when you are evaluating different
ethnicities in that case 325 AD roxie
vitamin D as to meet measured you cannot
rely anymore on total vitamin D
measurement let me show you at least a
few key studies just to exemplify what I
just discussed and the first study is a
study from 1996 from the group of land
Italy in in San Francisco they studied
and two groups of patients the first
group is patients with liver disease on
cirrhosis patients the second group was
a control group with healthy people in
those two groups they have been
measuring at the concentrations of the
VP album in total vitamin D
and free vitamin D if you look at the
data D BP is lower in the liver disease
group as well as albumin total vitamin D
is also lower in the liver disease group
about 50% of the concentration but free
vitamin D has almost the same
concentration what does it mean well it
means that if you look at total 25
hydroxy vitamin D you will think that
the group with liver disease it's much
more deficient and probably needs much
more supplementation to which optimally
if you look at the concentration of 3
right and indeed the concentrations are
similar even a little bit higher for the
liver disease group so which one is
right should we look at total vitamin V
of 3 right I mean while they linked it
to clinical outcomes and in that case
they looked at the prevalence of
osteomalacia which is a disease linked
to vitamin A deficiency what I found is
that the prevalence of this disease was
the same in the two groups so they
concluded that that case 3 vitamin D
free right and in the concentration is a
much better representation of the
clinical status of the patients then
total vitamin D because if total vitamin
D was really the correct marker we would
expect much more osteomalacia in the
group of liver disease patients which is
not the case so that's a very nice
example and first example of measurement
of free vitamin D in a specific disease
in this case cirrhosis or liver disease
patients the second example is about
pregnancy as I explained you DBB
concentration is is increase during
pregnancy and this is a study from a
hospital in Berlin's laboratory in
Berlin they took about 500 and
apparently healthy pregnant woman and
they measured
total 25 hydroxy vitamin D and energy
325 Alex if I can endorse pregnant woman
and they made correlations between these
two markers and other markers of
pregnancy or of vitamin E and O Lo and
calculated for all of them the
correlation coefficient the p-value and
you can see for example that for
gestational age there is no correlation
to total vitamin D and a strong
correlation to free by envy for calcium
it is the same p-value of about point 24
for total vitamin d point zero zero six
for measured free vitamin d one specific
alkaline phosphatase the same situation
album in the same situation low-density
lipoprotein in the same situation urea
the same situation adiponectin in the
same situation etc etc etc etc what does
it mean it means that in a pregnant
population the measurement of total 25
hydroxy vitamin D is not any more a good
mark or vitamin D metabolism in this
population there is a much much better
correlation of 325 AD roxie vitamin D
with a range of biomarkers the
conclusion of this study was was really
clear that during pregnancy people
should not be sure to tell vitamin E
anymore but should measure 325 c vitamin
D and I know this laboratory is starting
now to measure frequency for Galaxy
vitamin D in routine in a laboratory the
third study talks about the difference
between vitamin d2 and d3 and this study
was done in mice there has been some
debate in the literature boat should we
supplement people with vitamin d2 or
vitamin d3 and most of the papers were
showing that vitamin d3 seems to be a
little bit more efficient than whitening
it how was it established while they
looked at total vitamin D concentrations
again if you look at the concentration
of free vitamin D the situation is
completely different so what we did in
the study they took mice they divided
them into two groups
one group was supplemented with vitamin
D 2 only and the other group was
supplemented with vitamin d3 only they
didn't measure different parameters and
if you look on the graph in the graph a
this is total vitamin D concentration
you have to see a difference there we
know the difference between the d2 and
d3 group the concentration which I raged
are the same for the two groups now if
you look at graph D which is free
vitamin D concentration you can easily
see that the group which was
supplemented with d2 as a much higher
concentration than the group who have
supplemented with d3 and the reason for
that is the affinity of both forms for
DBP 25 out of C vitamin d2 as a lower
affinity with EBP than 25 at Roxy
vitamin d3
so if supplement mice with vitamin D to
the increase in 25 hydroxy vitamin D
will be much higher than if you shoulda
known this nice with please note with
vitamin d3 and as we have seen that the
free right I mean the concentrations are
very important that gives another viewer
another idea of which one is more
efficient between vitamin d2 and d3 in
this case right I mean d2 seems to be
more efficient to reach a higher level
of 25 C vitamin E this still has to be
proven in humans but it is an ongoing
research I know by different groups the
last part of my presentation is about
evaluation or measurement of 25 C
vitamin E of the free fraction you know
there are a lot of methods to measure
total 25a drop C vitamin D you have
chemiluminescence assays Aliza
assays LCMS methods still a few ras and
then coming also a few point-of-care
testing and some clinical chemistry
classes as well but how do you measure
the free fraction the 325 hydroxy
vitamin E
the very first method that was developed
in the 80s and is based on separation
methods so what you do in the first step
is to separate the free fraction from
the bone fractions how do you separate
the free fraction from the bone fraction
you can use two techniques centrifugal
intra filtration or dialysis then in a
new step you take the free fraction
which has been separated and you assay
it with sensitive radio energy or with a
very sensitive and CNS methods this
method is working very well and gives
very accurate results but it's not in
use anymore because of different
problems the first problem is it is very
very difficult to reproduce and the
people who have been using this method
in the 80s are not able to reproduce it
anymore
it is highly time and resources
consuming so clearly not usable in IVD
laboratories and not even even in
research laboratories anymore
it requires high volume of samples we
attend in both milliliters it uses
tritium and carbon-14 if you use thorium
energy or very very sensitive mass
spectrometry techniques and finally it
uses a few assumptions so it's not a
direct measurement so this method was
nice in the 80s get some good results in
papers that cannot be used anymore
and today so what people have been doing
the link during the last 10 years
they've been using calculations you can
also calculate free testosterone for
example in this case you can also
calculate free vitamin D and calculate
free vitamin D you need this equation on
which you can see that you will need the
concentration of total vitamin D the
concentration of albumin and the
concentration of D B so you need to be
to do three measurements from these
three measurements and using the
appropriate binding coefficients of both
albumin and VBP
you will have the concentration of fruit
and fight election either by using a
similar equation you can also calculate
bioavailable
free bioavailable 2500 C right enemy
which is the sum of three plus the album
in one fraction but this bioavailable
term is not really used anymore in in
research what are the drawbacks of
calculations well the first one is very
obvious you need to do to do three
essays per sample so 1025 C vitamin D D
BP and album ideally you should even do
a fourth essay which is the genotyping
of GDP the reason for that is you are
using biding coefficient in your
equation if you want to use the right by
the in coefficient you need to know
which form of DBP you have in your
sample as we have seen there are six
different forms each of these form cysts
seems to have different affinity
constant so if you do the B pigeon
typing you will have the mature form of
your sample you can use the right bite
inhibition you can have more accurate
calculated results the last problem and
it's it's really a big problem in in
most of the papers published in the last
five years is that vbp assays are not
all of equal quality there are two
different type of assays
some are based on monoclonal antibodies
and some are based on polyclonal
antibodies and in this case actually the
assays that are based on monoclonal
antibodies are inaccurate and the reason
for that is that those monoclonal
antibodies are actually too specific and
they do not recognize all the forms of
GDP so in some samples they will give
good results in some sample heading
other forms of DBP it will give no what
results which are inaccurate of course
if you have an inaccurate DVP
concentration you will have an
inaccurate calculation of freedom
fighter Roxie by gently so this is a big
issue because some of these papers gave
some conclusions in the last years most
probably some of these conclusions are
not correct and those studies needs to
be repeated with another method of free
vitamin D measurements
and now we come to the third method
that's was published very recently and
this is a direct measurement by Eliza
the principle of this method is
described here if you add a sample into
an analyzer plates coated with a 1 to 25
hydroxy by turning the antibody you will
have an equilibrium between the bound
form the free form and the form that is
captured by the antibody if you play on
the equilibrium between the bond form
the free form you allow the free form to
be captured by the antibody then there
is a washing step that will remove the
free form which is not bound and the
bound form and will only remain on the
antibody a representation of the
concentration of the free form the rest
is a classic analyzer and it allows you
to do a direct measurement of 325 Al
Aqsa vitamin D people showed that this
method is more accurate and calculations
especially in relation to PTH and
calcium which are two very important
bone markers together with vitamin D it
only requires one I say it's the three
three or four and because it's analyzer
it's accessible to any laboratory just
to show you some characteristics of this
assay the measuring range is between
point two and four typical grams per ml
as we have seen before
typical concentration for free right
energy are between two and eight so this
is perfectly located in the measurement
range the total precision of the essay
or CV for people which are familiar with
this denomination is about 5% or 4%
depending on the concentration the limit
of blank and limit of deflections are
below the lower sample concentrations
which is fine and the cross reactivity
of the asset worth 25 electrolyte and
indeed with about 80%
this method was validated against
dialysis and although the number of
samples was not very high it gave a good
correlation and a good slope which means
that the method was correctly calibrated
and validated against this dialysis
reference methods the method can also be
automated for large cohorts and also for
IBD use and this is just an example of
manual versus automated use you can see
on the left the standard curve which are
perfectly identical and on the right the
correlation performance samples which oh
that yes a as it is run manually or in
an automated form are giving the same
results to conclude on this free vitamin
D webinar a few take-home messages the
first one is obviously that currently
total 25 elected item India is used to
evaluate vitamin D deficiency in all
laboratories in the world
however when VDP concentration or DBP
form is different total 25 FC vitamin d
is not a good marker anymore in that
case three vitamin D concentration is
really the key third point if you do
direct measurement of three vitamin B it
is much more reliable than calculations
and we have seen for what reason in the
previous slides finally I'd like to
mention that with all the research that
has been done now the clinical utility
of free vitamin D is really currently
being demonstrated and implemented so
there are few a number of laboratories
and groups really working on the
clinical utility of this new marker and
really starting to implement it into
their routine measurements I would like
to finish my presentation with this
table which again show in a different
way the different cutoff values or the
different reference ranges for vitamin D
depending on his tradition in this case
vitamin D council
the underground society the food and
nutrition board and in some testing
laboratories or the rock ranches again
this is a complex situation and people
do not really know which one to take and
I hope and this is my feeling that free
vitamin D measurement will help to
harmonize at least partially dis table
and to provide new reference ranges
which will be universal across diseases
and healthy people I would like to thank
you anymore and would like to thank you
and very much for your attendance to
this webinar I hope you will now
consider free vitamin D as a new tool in
your vitamin D research or in your
research in general I hope this was
interesting for you and I'm sure there
will be questions so know there will be
a Q&A session thank you very much
Thank You Nicholas lyrics for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your questions into the box that appears
on your screen
and click on the done button what answer
is many of your questions since we have
time for let's get started our first
question is vitamin D is different from
the other hormones in the sense that
2508 vitamin D is measured while the
actual biologically active molecule
molecule is 125 o h2 vitamin D does it
make sense then to measure 325 o H
vitamin D or is the three hormone
hypothesis also about for vitamin G
right and this is a very interesting
question and I discuss a little bit
about that in my presentation so you're
right vitamin D and 25 hydroxy vitamin D
is not the active form of vitamin E so
it is the free hormone hypothesis really
valid for vitamin D as it is for T 3 T 4
T SH for example so as I explained this
is really linked to the transport
mechanism of 25a loop C vitamin D inside
of the cells so 25 hydroxy vitamin D to
be converted into the active form needs
to be transported into cells and this is
done through two different mechanisms
and in kidneys the main mechanism relies
on total vitamin D concentrations in
other tissues
it relies on three vitamin D
concentration so in the case three
vitamin D concentration is the most
important so in the case three vitamin D
is transported by passive diffusion
inside of the cells the free hormone
hypothesis is valid because the free
hormone concentration in this case is
directly linked to the concentration the
active form so you write the situation
is slightly different than for other
hormones but at the end the principle is
still valid
thank you for that answer our next
question is is there an interest for
measuring 2508 vitamin D in a pediatric
population
um this is a question that that is very
often raised because obviously vitamin D
is very important in pediatric
population I would say yes and no no
because in a in a pediatric population
there is no change of the DBB
concentration or no decrease or increase
in the BP concentration so in that case
you would think measurement of three
vitamin D is of no interest in this
population now the situation is
different if you work on the pediatric
population which has also some diseases
and I'm talking for example about kids
having kidney disease in that case you
have difference in the DVP concentration
and the measurement of three vitamin D
is very important the same if you have a
multi-ethnic cohort of of kids of
children's if you have blacks and white
children in your population again you
will have an interest of measuring free
vitamin D instead of total and this is
the same situation for all population if
you look at elderly population or
postmenopausal woman or other population
you should always look at do I have DBP
concentration which is increased or
decreased by any condition or to have
different ethnicities in my cohort or in
my report three which require free
vitamin D measurement
thank you our next question is what is
the cross reactivity of the eliza or
2500 h vitamin d2
thank you for that question this is
obviously an interesting question
especially in the United States were
vitamin d2 supplements are used
especially for high doses supplements
the cross reactivity of the sf-425
hydroxy vitamin d2 is about 80 percents
and this is pretty difficult to measure
actually because you cannot do spiking
experiments like you would do in other
essays too much across reactivity
because of the equilibrium and between
note of the GDP present and all these
things going around in the SI is not
that simple so what we did and what the
people did was to take the same antibody
put it in a total vitamin D Si and
measure the cross relativity in a total
vitamin D si because the cross
relativity is really a property of the
antibody whatever the SI you use more or
less you will have the same cross
reactivity for one metabolite
so it's about 80% this is not perfect
but it is in my point of view enough to
use it at least as a tool to measure 3
by 10 the concentrations a very good
question especially when you have a new
si coming up in in the field people are
asking how do you validate it what were
the experiments performance it ran so
Eliza was validated by by different
means and a direct validation against
dialysis as I showed you dialysis is
obviously a reference method for free
hormone measurements not only for
vitamin D but also for example for free
testosterone so this was a first
validation and also a validation of the
calibration of the assay the other
validation is slightly different if you
remember products from the presentation
when I presented that study on cirrhosis
patients that was made in the 80s this
group has been repeating the same study
with the same population so the samples
were not exactly the same but the
population was the same in term of
disease in them of age in them of
different parameters and they found the
same concentration the same mean
concentration using the direct
measurement by Eliza and using at that
time the ultra filtration technique so
somehow this is an indirect validation
because you can have the same
concentrations using this ultra
filtration and using the Eliza somewhere
2530 years later if in the same
population so you have direct validation
and you have indirect validation our
next question is are there published
reference ranges for 325 o h vitamin g
thank you for this very interesting
question which is obviously very
important if you want to use this marker
in in IVD laboratories you simply have
to know from which concentration your
operation will be efficient sufficient
or insufficient in 325 hydroxy vitamin D
there is no solid or concrete reference
which is published there are a number of
papers which are which have observed
values in different population and there
is a big paper which is about to be
published very soon with this kind of
ranges in a lot of different populations
this paper is is a very good paper I
haven't seen it yet but I know who is
working on that there will be a range of
key opinion leaders which have provided
325 loop C vitamin V data in different
populations and the living group of this
consortium is establishing statistics
min concentrations etc from all these
kind of different populations so this
will be published very soon and will
really help the laboratories from a
research perspective but also from an IT
perspective to establish their reference
ranges for fruit and factor of C vitamin
C okay it looks like we have time for
one more question
our next question is is the Eliza assay
you cited IBD marks T or FDA
this is obviously a very important
questions for those of you who were
working in in clinical labs in IBD labs
at the moment I know the Eliza essay is
only for research use only but as far as
I know end of this month or actually
beginning of this month it will be C e
mark so it will be usable at least in
Europe as an IV d essay also in
countries which accept the CE Marking
for the EMA FD marking I'm afraid we
should wait a little bit more and one of
the reason for that is that there is no
predicate device for free vitamin D in
the US so the way the FDA works requires
equivalent essay for a new essay to be
accepted by the FDA as this free vitamin
V liza is a new essay there are lot of
discussion with you how to proceed and
it will take a little bit more time for
the US people and US laboratories to be
able to use this Eliza
I would like to once again thank
Nicholas York's friends presentation I
would also like to thank lab words for
making today's educational webcasts
possible before we go I wanna let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through February of 2017 you will
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay these sure that
announcement would be your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye